workers at this garment factory
rushed to deliver thousands of face
masks the owner says more than two and a
half million were met here
to help nigeria control the spread of
covet 19
but as the africa free trade agreement
comes into effect
he foresees trouble ahead for the
continent's poorer countries
small and poor economies will always be
at a disadvantage
hopefully as time goes on we can get
special considerations
otherwise it will be difficult to
compete businesses in poor countries may
have their concerns
but overall experts say the agreement
will eventually benefit them
they believe the cheap cost of labor in
these countries
will attract more industries
into african trade can spur industrial
development
the level and pace of industrialization
among african countries
vary some will have advantage over
others but african countries need to buy
and sell raw and finished products among
themselves
landlocked tunisia currently imports
most of its needs
from bottled water to food and machinery
from big retail to local markets nigeria
is flooded with
imported products because of its weak
infrastructure and industrial base
the country will continue to depend on
imports making it difficult
for local industries to grow experts say
it's hard to see european and asian
multinational companies
giving up the trade advantage they've
held in africa
for a century products from europe
asia and africa's larger economies lined
the shelves
at nyami's biggest retail monopoly
consumers
prefer these brands traders say there
won't be many local goods on store
shelves unless government steps in
we should be given support government
should facilitate easy acquisition of
land and loans from banks
but it's hard to see how governments on
the continent can do that
without breaching the protectionism
rules of africa trade agreement
and the world trade organization ahmed
idris
al jazeera nyami